what's up guys are you ready to get Shah
Milan we're talking M night Shyamalan
cuz he's back in the theaters with after
earth do we want any more of this guy
today we have a pretty cool panel to
help us decide what is the worst M night
Shyamalan film of all time
first mr. Jordan Morris from one of the
funniest podcasts around Jordan Jessie
go hi how you for making me watch these
movies thanks Jordan and right next to
me
Kristian harloff you can check out his
show youtube.com slash schmoes no they
know a lot about film at so Dana well
thank you let's get into the holy grail
of sting I have a big stack of M night
Shyamalan films right here that I stole
from red box first uh The Sixth Sense I
think we can agree that this is a pretty
good film fantastic movie yeah by the
way Bruce Willis is a ghost um
unbreakable I like this movie I know
some people have problems with it I it's
actually my favorite genre on film I
love this movie next we have signs this
is a pre anti-semitic misogynistic Mel
Gibson yeah pre batched Joaquin Phoenix
yes I wouldn't know if it was pre this
wasn't my dad and gun hey we're here so
not bad not bad the village I think we
started to take a little bit of a turn
here it's hard to hate any movie whose
twist is future zoo this one to me the
cheap reveal it's when he started to buy
his own hype but it's not the worst of
the worst
can we dismiss the village we can it is
it it isn't these last three movies that
is the only reason we're not calling it
total garbage lady in the water the
happening and the last airbender so
Jordan one of these films stood out to
you as the worst yeah lady in the water
is one of the worst movies I've ever
seen in my life it's not even fun bad
it's just boring and pretentious and
dumb someone told this guy at one point
he read it in an article this could be
the next Spielberg after 6n2 it I am so
now I told my I told my son over bowl of
cereal about this magical wolf oh now
it's a movie I can do that I'm mmm lon
and it's just it his head just was too
big M night Shyamalan is a pretty big
character he plays a writer that it is a
foretold will save the world with that
beautiful writing right he won't speak
of you a new words your book will be the
seeds and many of his great thoughts
it's like if George Lucas cast himself
as obi-wan Kenobi like snow slow that
was close by though that is this is as
ridiculous is that what about Paul
Giamatti do you remember he held his
breath for like three minutes underwater
in that cavern looking for that that's
stuff oh you know you looking for the
magic mud to cure her of the grass wolf
wounds so the tree monkey skin I want to
like punch myself in my own because I
sound like a [ __ ] after lady in the
water
we had the happening it's bad it's I
mean it's really really bad and hard
hard to take it serious but you
shouldn't you should watch this movie as
a comedy and it really is one of the
funniest comedy since Caddyshack you
know hot dogs get a bad rap got a cool
shape dick got protein you like hot dogs
right yeah this this really I think goes
into that territory of Birdemic in the
room it's got crazy dummies falling off
roof it's got a guy who lays down in
front of a lawn mower well and what he's
also been able to do in his really bad
movies is make decent actors look
horrendous because Mark Wahlberg was
nominated for an Oscar and he looks like
he should be doing it
scenes with Pauly Shore in this film
planning on stealing something
no ma'am we're not plan on murdering me
in my sleep what no I have something
here that tells us that this is an
especially bad movie now this is a quote
from Mark Wahlberg the happening it is
what it is king trees man the plants get
historically bad a terrible film I think
we can all agree yes happening yes now
there's one more film in the running The
Last Airbender I hate this movie I hate
it so much I was watching this film I
just so angry at everything I mean I
felt bad for the CGI characters that
were in it I felt bad for everyone that
had to be a part of this thing it sucks
they pray the weakest towns and villages
we should go visit some of these towns
on I need to tell you something what is
it all I ran away before they trained me
to be the avatar you don't care about
anyone either like that you know in this
whole this whole look you should and you
should make it cool even with the
fighting style give you something new
give me something that is not so generic
and vanilla it looked like they just
stole the mousse from your mom's yoga
class yes they went to yoga at the Y
observed for 10 minutes and told the
kids just do that and we will throw
special effects out of her hand my mom
goes to curves okay with the lady in the
water it's his own crap it was garbage
it's hard to watch but this is a movie
this from source material that people
loved
so you're basically peeing all over it
began saying I'm Shyamalan and now I'm
going to force you to watch this giving
you hope and then crushing that hope
with a bad CGI dragon guys it seems like
none of us are going to budge of what we
think is the worst cha Milan so let's
let the audience decide in one sentence
tell me why your choice is the worst
Jordan it's a fairy tale with racial
stereotypes in place of magic Christian
alright so all I have to say is this if
you're a fan of the original series
watch it and then watch this you'll hate
it it's it's not faithful to the
original source material at all he
thought he was AMA on my head so big I'm
the best the movie stinks and it still
is a smell on it no one remembers the
other ones everyone rumors this piece of
garbage
everything Shyamalan attempts in this
film goes wrong and the villain is the
wind alright guys we've pled our cases
now it's up to you to determine what is
the worst M night Shyamalan film of all
time is it lady in the water The Last
Airbender The Happening one of the
movies we threw on the floor or did
after earth come out of nowhere to take
it leave your comments let us know we
will tabulate your answers and annotate
it right here and you will see what is
truly the worst M night Shyamalan film
of all I want to thank today's awesome
guest Jordin Morris
Kristian harloff I have to put this down
as a burning a hole in my life
oh we have hand sanitizer in the lobby
thanks for watching everybody I'm Hal
Rudnick bye-bye
[Music]